زلزال اقوى واشد يضرب مجددا قبل ان يستفيق
المنكوبون من هول الصدمه الاولى كابوس حرم
الالاف من النوم خلال الايام الماضيه على
الارض هزات ارتداديه بالجمله وعلى وسائل
الاعلام ومواقع التواصل اخبار وتوقعات
وتحذيرات من زلزال مدمر جديد يفوق ما فعله
سابقه في السادس من فبراير الجاري فما
حقيقه تلك الادعاءات وما راي العلم في ذلك
هذا الرجل فرانك هوجربيتس الذي خطف
الانظار عن الزلزال خلال الايام الماضيه
اصاب في توقعاته حول زلزال يضرب المنطقه
وهو العالم المختص بالزلازل وما ان وقع
الزلزال حتى اصبح الجميع يراقب كل كلمه
يقولها او ينشرها عسى ان تكتب للبعض
الفرصه بالنجاه من الكارثه القادم رغم
زوبعه التي اثارها العالم هولندي يرى
خبراء ان توقعاته تلك ليست سوى كلام عام
على حد وصفه فما معنى ان تقول ان روسيا
معرضه لهطول الثلوج في فصل الشتاء مثلا
هذا حديث عام لان روسيا معروفه بذلك
والبقعه التي ضربها الزلزال في تركيا
معروفه بزلزله ارضها منذ الاف السنين ولم
يتمكن العلم الى اليوم من التنبؤ باوقات
حدوث الزلازل لا في تركيا ولا في غيرها من
المناطق اما عن امكانيه حدوث زلزال اقوى
بعد ايام من الزلزال الاول فهذا بحسب
العلماء احتمال ضعيف
احتمال ان يكون زلزال القوي بمثابه انذار
وتمهيد لوقوع زلزال اقوى منه في غضون
الايام الثلاثه المواليه احتمال ضعف
للغايه ولا يتجاوز سته في المئه العلم
يقول انما حدث في منطقه كهرمان مرعش ربما
كان ناتجا عن عدم تفريغ الطاقه المتراكمه
حيث ان اخر زلزال كبير حدث في هذه النقطه
كان قبل نحو 500 عام وهي نقطه حساسه
تتقاطع فيها ثلاث صفائح تكتونيه هي
الاناضول والصفائح الافريقيه والعربيه هذه
الصفائح الثلاث تتحرك وتتصادم وتدفع بعضها
بعضا ونتيجه لذلك يتراكم الكثير من الطاقه
وتتشكل خطوط صدع كبيره جدا لذا فان حدوث
زلازل صغيره على فترات متقاربه شيء ايجابي
في حد ذاته لانها تؤدي الى تفريغ الطاقه
المتراكمه بشكل تدريجي ولن يحدث تحفيز من
بعض الصفائح لبعض لتنفجر بشراسه في وجه
البشر كما حدث مؤخرا
ما حدث في تركيا يبين ان زلزالين حفز
بعضهما بعضا وهذه الحاله ليست شائعه في
علم الزلازل فزال الاول تسبب في حدوث
الزلزال الثاني على خط صدع شرق الاناضول
اذا وبحسب العلم لا يمكننا التنبؤ بموعد
الزلزال الكارثي القادم على خط الصدع نفسه
على الاقل في الفتره الحاليه لكن ما
يمكننا فعله ان نعيد النظر في تصميم مباني
تتحمل الهزات القويه
والموجات الارتداديه القادم